I have a list of questions here okay
like I said and we're going to go up a
level on the labor Simulator for every
question okay and you tell me when we
get to a level where you just you either
tap out and we stay there for a while or
we can move up to that next level first
question you'll find them a hard body
we're going to start off in your
wheelhouse here buddy okay first
question what is a better film Godfather
yeah
or Good Fellas oh god father Godfather
told me I thought you were going to ask
me a hard question okay well how about
this I thought you were Godfather part
one or Godfather Part Two Godfather part
one now if you asked me Michael what's a
better movie Godfather or Me Myself and
Irene
then I don't know because now we're
talking about two ingredients there's no
way you like me myself and Irish my
favorite movie really oh yeah really
it's an amazing every scene on that in
that film is okay well we're going up a
level okay
tell me when we get to
hold on okay
no how about we're gonna do this
why don't you tell me
who's a better basketball player Michael
Jordan yeah or Lebron James I'm more of
a Tiger Woods fan myself Tiger Woods I
would say Tiger Woods uh
I I I know that I don't like LeBron
James
because he's a jerk and a big lib and I
know that Michael Jordan is at least
somewhat nice to uh conservatives
so I don't know anything about
basketball
but I would say I support Michael Jordan
I'm getting very nervous by the way as
you keep uh yeah playing with that
machine you know you said you can't feel
it so I just no no I feel it hold on did
it kick in it kicked okay yeah okay so
tell me Michael Jordan or LeBron James
because you're talking about Tiger Woods
over there it's sort of like I'm just
being tickled right now it's a little
okay all right uh yeah I would say uh
Michael Jordan
Michael Jordan okay sir yeah now you're
feeling it over there yeah all right
level three there we go yeah okay every
fall season from henceforth you can only
indulge in one
pumpkin spice lattes or candy corns
I would say if I could only pick one
clearly the pumpkin spice latte would be
my answer uh because
well you got to pick up that machine
like that
because candy corn is great but you know
you can only eat
so I I expected this to be uncomfortable
and to hurt a little tickling but well
you know what we have something for that
it's called level four is it level okay
great congratulations
all right
does playing sports provide a value in
society oh yeah yeah it does it does
because it teaches you teamwork and it
trains your body it's important to drink
it's important to train your body you
know and so that you can handle things
like being electrocuted and but it's it
teaches you sacrifice you know and
that's that not everything in the world
is about you it teaches you it
and so that's that's why I support have
you tried out for a sport level five oh
yeah I level five okay I um
I I played Little League for eight years
did you know that no I did and I think I
probably got three hits
in in all the years and
I I played right field a lot of the time
because this is true in all of baseball
but especially in Little League
especially in Little League it that's
where they put you and you don't yeah
you don't uh play very well and so the
one thing I would do though David I
don't know if I've told you this but in
because I couldn't hit the ball very
well what I would do is I would lean
into pitches like like sort of Don
Baylor you know and so my on base
percentage was actually pretty high but
my uh my batting average was not not
great battery cover is not great so last
night we saw a hit in the Dolphins
football game let's talk football for a
second we're two a tug about Loa was
knocked out of the game would you allow
your sons to play football
uh you know I'm not at great fear that
my sons will exactly be eligible or
desired for football teams just I'm this
is no false modesty but we're not
exactly sort of hulking uh linebackers
in the Knowles family uh but but if they
really wanted to I would consider it but
it's a real it is a real risk I mean I
would ask you you know I mean you you
played at a very high level yeah would
you would you think about it all the
time I think that uh I think I am going
to allow my sons to play football
because
there are so many advantages to playing
the sport in terms of discipline and
punctuality and things I'm a better man
for having played the sport but when I
see something that happened last night I
do get fearful are you ready for level
are you ready for level six I guess I am
okay well this is perfect timing for
this because from Twitter on a scale of
one to a Kamala Harris speech how
painful is this right now it's not
painful it's just very
hahaha
it's just because it it it's not for
those who are just watching right now
it's not
it it is not constant it's just like a
little it's it's active
it's like
it becomes harder it's just like someone
it's like what I do with my kid or if
you're just sitting there he's just like
you're just like you're good right now
then
I gotta Define good
thing goes to 24. oh my God so eight now
now it's starting to become somewhat
painful okay but
how about this who's worse at keeping
Internet Secrets Adam Levine or Hillary
Clinton
you're online you're on level eight I
would say uh uh
lavina's words
because he didn't wipe the hard drive
but Hillary she has bleach if Adam
Levine had bleach bid he'd still have a
perfectly fine situation okay all right
does praying before a ball game give you
an advantage
yes praying always gives you an
advantage no matter what you're doing
now does that mean does that mean that
you're going to win the ball game
because
no one else in there buddy sir it's not
like the new age like you're gonna
manifest it I'm gonna win the ball game
it's it's like it it it just when you
are closer to God
relationship
I clearly should have prayed more before
this segment how about this one yeah
spite Pagan Roots will you allow your
children
to trick-or-treat
talk to me about Halloween Michael I
love Philly Pagan it's a great
holiday
because it's right before All Saints Day
so it's not it's not Pagan at all of
course
of course so no problem with Halloween
but I
I won't let them do
I won't let them do like weird devil
stuff like they've gotta no no no good
no weird devil stuff that's what I
thought you gotta dress up like last
year last year my kid was he went as
Saint Michael the Archangel so I had him
in like a little gladiator costume you
know and he had like these little
you're doing great man we're up to 12.
I'm good
I'm good so so how so trick-or-treating
is good right
this is good no devil stuff no devil
stuff I know you're a learned man when
it comes to the Immaculate Conception
tell me the next guy tell me what you
know about the Immaculate Reception
you know so people
misunderstand the Immaculate Conception
because they think it refers to the
Virgin birth of Jesus Christ but it
the conception of Mary with that
original sin and so uh that most people
don't know that and uh and I certainly
don't know a damn thing about the
immaculate literacy
so could you please enlighten me as to
what that is the Immaculate Reception
was a football play it was a pass that
was completed from Terry Bradshaw with
the Pittsburgh Steelers to Franco Harris
and it really defied the odds and I
think that it got the nickname the
Immaculate Reception do you find that uh
sacrilegious in any way I find it
somewhat sacrilegious but not there are
many more offensive things that I've
heard it I don't think it like quite
reaches the point of you know like
blasphemy or something I heard you in
there talking about divorce um I know
you were also a learned man when it
comes to King Henry VII well he could be
divorced from from Catherine what would
you have done if you were King Henry VII
and your wife couldn't bear children and
you couldn't get divorced what would you
have done in his shoes well would I well
look I mean there's no River so long it
doesn't okay
[Laughter]
King Henry you were saying I can't I
can't
hear what it was but
how are you doing are you hurting you
tell me we need a safe word
like
oh it's it's awful because it like it
does you just
it does there hurt to some degree but
it's it also tickles it's okay it's like
you well
they call you you're known as
Nostradamus my question for you
Nostradamus is would you want to know
how long you will live down to the exact
day would you want to know I think I do
know like two more minutes
have you ever pretended to know more
about sports to impress a woman
uh
well like
I guess it would have to be me
anything about sports so if I ever like
even mentioned a football game would be
it would probably be
what is the most important line in the
U.S Constitution
but
for the general welfare
because it proves that our constitution
is a document intended for the common
good that's beautiful DeSantis or Trump
24. yeah you if you voted today
[Laughter]
like
[Applause]
if I had to pick between only those two
yeah those are my two choices
I'll have you know you've made it higher
than uh Ben Davis yeah I'm not surprised
but what am I at
we're up to level 16 right now I'm only
in 16. what oh no
uh I would say
I'm very impressed by DeSantis but I
just haven't seen him at a national
level yet so I I'd probably I'd probably
I'd probably trust Trump a little bit
more but if there were a primary
DeSantis could totally convince me
because he's got all the right instincts
what you know you're a Yankees fan right
yeah you're up to 17 by the way you're a
Yankees fan Aaron judge is chasing the
uh the record for 62 home runs yeah I
mean he what would you do if you caught
that ball you given that back to judge
or you are you going to eBay with the
ball no I'm uh
I'm at least keeping it for me and my
personality but it's it's I'm glad you
phrased the question that way because
officially the home front record is what
it's like 73 because a big-headed berry
bonds yes but that's a steroid it's
totally fake so Maris is the record
holder yes and and judge is totally
gonna bring my my colleague Jake crane
on that you're at 18. who affected more
change in the world Michael Martin
Luther or Martin Luther King Jr this is
from director Mark Martin Luther Martin
Luther created the modern era he he was
he was the end of the the Middle Ages
and uh he just completely created
Modern Life whereas Martin Luther King
did sort of establish a new constitution
in America through the Civil Rights Act
but that is different uh in in degree
from what Martin Luther did all right
we're almost done do aliens exist no
are you sure I'm positive I'm not
totally positive but I'm like
I'm playing 99 positive 99 is pretty
good yeah I have one for you here a uh a
Catholic a Catholic a Protestant and a
Jew walk into a bar yeah they should
watch where they're going am I right
I knew I could get you to laugh at my
jokes Michael as long as I had a labor
simulator
last last three here one do you blame
your producer Ben Davies for your loss
yes because I don't know anything about
football so I could have just picked by
throwing darts at a dartboard and I
would have done better than freaking
Davies
I think I'm like losing the whole thing
right now because because maybe this is
genius war room I think you're good I
think you're doing good uh last two one
from my wife do you appreciate your wife
more after this right here I hate this
experience no I didn't know it was so
funny to give birth I didn't know it's
like like is the experience that I now
believe labor is is like what I watch a
Norm Macdonald special thank you
wow it sounds great it should be eager
to give birth last one level 25. this is
from your wife sweet little Elisa sweet
little Lisa yes would you be able to
come home and help with the kids today
at 2 30. at 2 30 yes well 2 30 is
usually when I go to
this is why explain it to me you're too
thirties right explain it please explain
it to me all right you're done what am I
at 25 you might hit 25 yes suck it
Davies all right well Davey's only made
it to 10. oh you made it to 10 10. yeah
that um
that was a very that was a very
degrading experience I'm going to be
honest with you yeah I would have bet
against you to make it today no you know
I
I actually have
a relatively decent
uh pain tolerance
but
I did not count I I thought that I would
be able to handle the the pain of it
what I didn't Bank on
the tickling
[Music]
thank you